what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos let's try to get 2 000 likes okay
all right today we're gonna react to um
another mgtow Channel called it where
the did the Good Men went go I don't
know just pull up the video okay it
doesn't oh where are the good men with
an air for men and for this talk I'm
taking some time to speak with the
ladies for many years now countless
women have been asking the question
where did all the good men go this talk
is dedicated to helping those women get
an answer to that question and perhaps
solve some of their confusion over what
to do about it you will have to pardon
the bluntness and what you're going to
hear in this talk I'm afraid the truth
of this matter is a sugar repellent it
just can't be coated with Sweetness in
order to make it more palatable put in
the simplest terms the answer to where
have all the good men gone is anywhere
but around you and yes I mean that about
any woman clueless enough to have to
even ask where the good men went to
begin with in other words if you gotta
ask you're the problem the mechanics of
all this are simple even if they are a
bit ugly it breaks down into two areas
of life social and political socially
you've been trained to think that your
vagina is carte blanche to operate
relationships with no sense of fairness
or reciprocity take a visit to any
dating site and you will see what I mean
there's no shortage of profiles from
women who actually use the words I want
to be treated like a princess yes and
this is what we tell young girls you're
a princess you know which I I know it's
good intentions but you know the the
path to the road to hell is paved with
good intention so you know this is what
happens when we tell women that we're
amazing from the time we're like five
years old and then less obvious but just
as caustic I want a man who knows how to
treat a woman even more common are
profiles that contain those cinnamons
you know how man I want it I want a man
that knows how to treat a woman oh my
gosh I should make a dating app profile
as a guy one day and swipe even if they
don't use the exact verbage these women
establish their status as
right in the storefront window and you
really don't know why good men take a
sniff of you and do a U-turn right about
now some of you watching this will write
everything I'm saying off to misogyny
first just so you know good women can't
stand your sorry asses either there are
some really decent women with more to
give a relationship than an occasional
blob and a wish list from Tiffany's
there are enough of the wrong kind of
women out there for sake that they've
inspired a couple of social movements
aimed to either get away from them or
just to figure out how to pump and dump
them let that sink in for just a moment
all of this leaves good women in sort of
a pickle they've been swaddled up in the
masses of entitled gold digging skeezers
who are now accepted as the default
model of modern femininity you could lie
to yourself all day long about this if
you want to you can even convince
yourself that the only reason that a man
would reject a high maintenance woman
baby with a dollar sign tattooed on her
mons is because he hates women it won't
change the fact Max these men don't hate
women they do however hate women like
you
no and that's the thing it's like I went
to Miami and these girls on stage were
saying they needed two grand a month to
stay home I'm just like you realize
that's like what is an average salary
like I don't know four four thousand
dollars in the US but my guess anyways
four or five but I'm like that's that's
half a salary on you for what what are
you doing that's so special that hatred
is not a product of malice but wisdom
these men are also frustrated by the
fact that early on it can be difficult
telling the difference between women
like you and adults who might be worth
their time that leaves some really
decent women getting blowback because of
the rent Seekers politically there's
another reason that men have stamped
reject to your forehead aside from the
fact that you are shallow selfish high
maintenance terminally immature and
generally foolish you're dangerous I
don't mean Brooklyn and that's they are
dangerous because of the way are today
okay yeah men would be willing to put up
with more well they already put up with
a lot but I I don't think men would be
so skeptical about getting married if
the laws were not the way they are my
heart have a good choir move on
dangerous I mean gray steel doors ruined
reputation and ended life dangerous
what's that you say you don't understand
what I mean well let me put it another
way a four-year-old in a grown woman's
body plus a raging sense of entitlement
plus emotional reasoning plus a society
that lauds this crazy in women
equals a life-altering accident waiting
impatiently to happen when you really
examine the facts on the ground
critically you come to understand that
we're not for your vagina the average
man would look at you like a stinging
insect or perhaps a dirty bomb women
like you are enough to make intelligent
men keep a CBR suit in the trunk of
their cars the fact that most men ignore
your toxic Thorns is their fault the
fact that you have those Thorns is yours
thus this little chat today understand
I'm trying to help you here you're
saying you want a good man it is
indisputable that any man who approaches
the definition of good would consider a
relationship with you like parking on
train tracks and taking a nice long nap
is it that bad is it that you know all
right something has to change and it is
not men no and that's that's my thing
because you know at first I used to
think red pill stuff was was harsh until
I started looking at the numbers and I
was like you know what from a historical
perspective women are pretty bad in
general like I can't go to your profile
on match.com or wherever you are trying
to rope in a malleable wallet with a
penis and do some editing remove all the
crap about how special and deserving you
are got all the references to princess
real man and anything else that points
to your entitlements replace that stuff
with what you have offer this may be
particularly challenging for you as at
this point you don't have a lot going
for you in that department it may be
helpful to pretend what you would have
to give if you were a grown woman of
good values even if you don't mean it
put in things like being morally
supportive loyal reasonable fair and
consistent talk about how you value the
sometimes disparate needs evident in any
relationship and about your commitment
to find rational solutions to conflicts
in order to give both sides a fair shape
then and this part is real important
look at your profile again and realize
you had to lie your ass off to even
appear
you were worth the attention of a decent
man that will or whether it should leave
you at a Crossroads you can revert back
to being the real you worthless as that
is or on the chance that something
worthwhile has shaken loose in your head
you can start to figure out that the
artificial person you have created in
your profile is actually the person you
are supposed to be not just for finding
a man but for living life is something
other than vacuous dead weight a boil on
the ass of humanity if you follow that
path you will come to yet another
Crossroads you will find yourself in the
company of other women well and this is
the thing we live in such a delusional
world where a woman with two children
from two different fathers and a chest
tattoo will say that she is deserving of
a high value man that she can attain
that like this is reality and it's crazy
because they'll be nice pleasant women
but they're still it's still crazy
delusion who also can't stand women like
the one you used to be and you will be
frustrated by the legions of low rinse
skanks that now serve as role models for
our young girls in fact and then yeah
look at the media the only person I
could think of in the media that's like
a role model of a good wife is Savannah
James and in all honesty and Blake
Lively actually she seems she seems good
but in all honesty I I don't really I've
never really heard Savannah James talk
I've never really heard it he started
asking where have all the good women
gone then you will realize that the only
way for you to stand out is to stand up
stand up and talk about so many women
who are giving all women a bad name you
do that and you'll have no problem
finding a decent man don't do it and you
will be here next year looking for
suckers who respond to your dating
profile looking not for a man but a mark
and fueling the changing attitudes of
men who have had a belly full of women
like you well that's it for this talk
ladies your appreciation for this
life-chasing information is easily
expressed I like this guy he's kind of
funny yeah and that's the thing like
girls will list all of the stuff they
want all of the stuff but don't list
anything so you know Fair criticism so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments like the video on your way out
seriously like the video Let's Get 1000
likes subscribe I'll talk to you guys
next time